foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
this is the Ramsay show where America
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined this
hour by best-selling author Christina
Ellis and we are here for you America to
take your calls to give you the right
Next Step for your money and for your
life so give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five that is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five well Christina we're back in the
saddle here and it was a big week last
week you hosted with Rachel Cruz for the
first time for the first time I've never
seen you happier so I like that kind of
excitement for us today can you do that
I can do that man okay well there's a
lot going on in the world Christina and
a lot of fear a lot of anxiety a lot of
poor decisions being made this time of
year as we start to enter the holidays
yeah and hopefully none of those are
coming from you oh gosh I hope not I try
not to but I mean no promises well the
Halloween uh fall Decor went up with the
camel household and I'm proud to say we
were under budget good for you yes my
wife did very well with that I'm not a
big Halloween decor person as far as
spending goes yeah I lean more into the
like fall Decor versus the kind of
creepy Halloween I grew up Arabic
Baptist so we were not we were one of
the lights out Homes at Halloween if you
know what I'm talking about America do
not come here grandma would hand out
like like the little Christian tracks
with a little candy bag yeah sweet
that's how I grew up James knows what
I'm talking about things it was always a
fall festival and you could be like a
disciple a dress up as like yes the
Autumn's Harvest Festival that's right
but it is an exciting time I did a media
hit this morning with our friends in
Dayton talking about how people can save
around the holiday times
and a lot of the times it's just
impulsive the marketing is more
aggressive than ever even already in uh
you know early mid-october here we're
already seeing Amazon Prime days
tomorrow stock up and then you go wait
it's not a sale they just marked it up
to a hundred dollars and then now it's
down to 50 and they're telling you it's
a sale it was always fifty dollars right
well it's crazy that they're even
bringing fee here into Halloween candy
shopping you were saying in your media
hit recently that they're talking about
how there might be a chocolate shorter
so it came from Hershey's I can't trust
them when it comes to Candy news of
course of course they want you to rush
out and buy it all yeah I'm not falling
for the fear-mongering so uh it all
comes down to planning early sticking to
a budget do your research I was at
Costco this weekend on a Sunday
just limit the chaos abounds at Costco
on a Sunday but we got our Halloween
candy we did it good for you yeah you
probably got a big old bag of it too you
have to it's it's the Costco way it's
the Costco way well and I think it's so
important too right now as we get ready
to go into the holidays to set your
budget it's so easy once you get into
the holiday mode and you're you're
thinking about who needs a gift and
what's going to be what decorations we
need to just start spending like crazy
but now is the time to start having
those conversations with your spouse you
know what can we afford this year and
for some people it's not going to be a
lot I did a story recently where
somebody was we were talking about what
are the biggest sacrifices you've made
with your money
um in order to get through the baby
steps and somebody was like one year we
didn't give gifts at all I know the
horror right I don't love your family
then right Christina of course no but it
was a temporary thing it was one year
and now they're debt free and they're
giving great gifts so it's like it may
be worth it for a year if that's where
you're at and that's what you need to do
set some boundaries lower the
expectations sacrifice I love it will
you call in John jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Christy is kicking us off this hour in
Knoxville Tennessee Christy welcome to
the show
Hi how are
you so great how can we help today
so I finished my PhD in May and I took a
position at a regional University moved
across country I took a non-tuner trap
position making forty five thousand
dollars which is a very disheartening
coming out of my PhD program
um so another College within the
university is has asked me to apply for
a position in a different College not
necessarily my specialty but it would
increase my salary by 25 to 30 000 I
have about 15 years of work left and the
university puts in nine percent
retirement towards for me matching for
my salary and so I'm like do I take it
do I jump into something that I don't
know as well for the money and the
long-term retirement gain or do I stay
put
well they think you're qualified why
don't you think you're qualified
um well I'll tell you I spent 20 years
this year and principal and this
are uh department is in speech and
hearing science which is actually what
my PhD is in but I don't have a speech
and hearing Science Background so I'm a
little nervous feeling like you know PhD
in this but you don't think you're
qualified
yes goodness then I'm definitely not
qualified Christy this sounds like a
home run I think it sounds like there's
just fear because you haven't actually
done it professionally well Christy is
this something you want today
you know I do I tell you what I'm very
money driven and I love you know making
more money so taking the 45 000 salary
was like I said very disheartening so
the money itself is super intriguing
what is the the job where you're making
45k what are you doing in that position
I am um a clinical instructor so which
is about the lowest wrong you can get in
higher ed and is it in speech and
learning
no it's actually in special education so
it's something is an area that I know
extremely well I could do it in my sleep
um and there's you know there's not a
lot of challenge to it it's just easy to
do
I mean I'm with George it sounds like
you're qualified for the new position it
pays more
and yeah you're not looking for a
challenge at this stage of the game but
I'm gonna challenge you to take that
lead to a degree you're a driven person
anyone who can finish a PhD can do this
and so I if I'm you I'm taking the leap
and it's not much of a leap they think
you're qualified I think you're
qualified and Christy needs to believe
in Christy at this point and go you know
what there might be a little bit of a
learning curve but I have a PhD in this
area and I'm gonna figure it out because
I'm Christy and instead of being
undervalued in the position that you're
currently in you're going to be making
75 000 instead of 45 right
yes that's worth it yeah if this was
Survivor and I said Christy are you
willing to take a job that you have a
PhD in for thirty thousand dollars you
would say yeah I'm doing it
um absolutely I would well thank you I
appreciate the clarification I just yeah
it was shocking I wasn't expecting them
to come recruit me
um so it was it was a little bit of a
curveball but um thank you absolutely
well worst case scenario you go back to
what you were doing and you'll probably
make more because they're probably going
to base it off of your current salary
which if it's 75 you go back to special
ed and they go well if we want Christy
we've got to come up with 75. if we're
going to cause her to make this jump
again right yeah and finishing a PhD
that's not easy that in and of itself is
a big challenge you've proven that you
can do big challenges so I would I would
take the leap yeah I mean if Ken Coleman
was sitting here he would be yelling at
you to take this job this is what you
put your life's work into with this PhD
so it's time to step into it and it
might be scary but I I think you're
going to look back and say man I'm so
glad I did that the fear and the doubt
that voice was louder at the time but
I'm so glad I stepped further than that
and took that jump so we're cheering you
on Christy congrats on the on the
promotion well deserved this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis this
is the Ramsay show you can give us a
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money maybe
you're trying to get out of debt get on
a budget begin investing in Building
Wealth buy a house sell a house you name
it there's so many pieces of our life
that are tied to money and we just want
to help you take the right next step in
your financial future
Dean joins us up next in Olympia
Washington Dean welcome to the show
hey how you guys doing today we're doing
great how can Christina and I help
well I'm kind of a late bloomer I'll try
to uh explain it the best I can I I
became debt free last December uh
probably made about 90 last year one
income family my wife's retired
um the only Investments or anything I've
started is a Roth IRA about 14 000 at
the end of the year last year I was able
to combine the two years and do it at
the end of the year and get both years
into
and at the same time and then I have
about
160 K in the bank
uh debt free mortgage no mortgage house
was paid for it's probably worth three
and a quarter maybe three at the least
in this market
um looking to retire uh in a couple
years if possible I'd like to retire in
a couple years
but I don't really have that many
Investments going just kind of wanted me
to get a little uh pointed in the right
direction of
you know kind of spooked about the stock
market and stuff right now it doesn't
appear to be doing very well yeah this
is a rough time to get in and go well it
was a smart thing to invest kind of kind
of vehicle kind of vehicle heavy right
now too I have
two or three vehicles and a boat to sell
which will probably bring me another 30
or something you know so I should have a
you know definitely have a couple
hundred K in the bank free and clear by
the end of the year okay so that
includes your emergency fund do you know
how much of that would be an emergency
fund of three to six months for you guys
uh it would be included in that so okay
subtract whatever the 18 Grand 20 grand
you think
yeah okay
so that leaves you in a good cash
position and now I want to make this
cash work for you but it sounds like
you're worried to put it into the market
and because that money could take a dip
between now and the next year
yeah I do have an investment broker that
my cross that my Roth is through that he
recommended he's pretty sharp that I
that I hesitate for a little bit here
because he's pretty sharp and what's his
hesitation you know it's what's
it just seems to think it's taken quite
a dip right now and uh I guess his
opinion it wouldn't hurt to wait till
the end of the year and see which
direction it's going
I thought it was good advice but I don't
know enough to know
well we we never recommend anyone try to
time the market and right now while the
stock market is down it's a fun time
because the stocks are on sale and so
all those shares you buy when the market
comes back up the shares go with it and
you bought them all at a discount
essentially
yeah everything's for sale now right
yeah I mean it's it's for sale it's a
good time to be going in
um I know that there's a lot of fear
right now but what is it that Warren
Buffett says what is this quote where
it's like be greedy when others are
fearful be fearful when others agree
yeah is that it yep sounds right
but I also understand being near
retirement it can be a little bit
nerve-wracking because you want secure
Investments we have really great
investment professionals smart investor
Pros if you go to ramsaysolutions.com
that are probably going to be a little
bit more confident about going into the
market they're kind of going to advise
you not to try to time the market that
are going to advise you to do steady
investing and just stay consistent we
always say time in the market beats
timing the market and that's the truth
the longer you've been in the game and
the longer you stay there I mean how how
soon would you need to withdraw like are
you talking you're 61 you want to retire
at 65.
yeah I would maybe at 62 but uh with the
way the inflation and everything's going
I'm probably gonna go to be able to go
I'm probably gonna have to go till 65 if
work for the state the penalties are
pretty heavy what's your income
I made 90 last year I'll probably make
120 this year and make at least a
hundred
every year from here on out and what are
the retirement options through your job
uh it's purrs purse two
have you been contributing to that
yeah they they contribute they pull it
out of your payroll
so what would that amount to when you
retire
they said right now it's sitting about
three grand a month if I bail at 62 it's
three grand a month if I if I work till
65 it's an extra thousand dollars a
month so for those three years
they're going to keep a thousand dollars
a month of it so we're saying it's 65.
you retire 65 you're going to get a
pension to four grand a month until you
pass away
yeah not counting Social Security great
and so with a paid for house and very
little expenses is that not enough do
you think you can make it with that
I think so as long as inflation doesn't
keep going super crazy another thing
that that's really beneficial that my
wife's travels so we have
uh
right now it's a hundred a piece and
when she turned 65 here shortly it'll be
down to 50 bucks a piece a month for us
for good insurance
great and that's one of the big things
that's keeping us from
people in my line of business well yeah
the hiring is those health care costs
your medical can be up to eight it's up
to 800 a piece
to retire you know or 1500 bucks a month
for both of us and ours will be like 100
bucks a month yeah so that's one of the
reasons I was thinking about being able
to bail at 62. well I would I would keep
hanging on for now until you crunch the
numbers and maybe that's with a
smartvester pro to go all right if I
bail a 62 we have more than enough to
cover our expenses and still enjoy
retirement I don't want you to just
scrape by because you guys could live
another 35 years and so it's not going
to be a fun time in retirement when
you're just able to cover your bills and
keep up with inflation
oh exactly so I'd get that second
opinion and if you sold those uh you
know a car in the boat you got an extra
30 grand now you can invest you know
almost what 150 160 Grand into the
market and you let that grow for another
five six seven years while you live off
that pension well now we're talking you
could have a few hundred thousand
dollars in that account you know even if
it's a taxable brokerage account that
you could withdraw you know four or five
percent from every year and that can
last you a long time
to supplement your income
what's the average risk in the market
right now I mean the chances of losing
all your money at once are pretty slim
as far as a chance we are looking at an
apocalyptic situation if it goes to zero
yeah if that happens we've got much
bigger issues yeah and so what we're
seeing right now is it's down 20 25 and
historically when there's been a you
know a dip like this within two years or
back to where it was and better and so
the economy has always done better than
it was doing you know when you look back
over a long period of time a long
stretch of History
and uh one of our smart investor Pros
they can walk you through that to give
you that confidence right now I don't
want fear letting you let you sit on the
sidelines with your cash just sitting in
the bank
that's not going to give you a great
retirement
yeah that money wasn't there till
recently until I uh sold a rental house
my one and only rental house and was
able to become debt free and put that
money in the bank and all that too so I
made made some pretty good decisions
over the year to get to this point over
the years to get to this point yeah I
mean at six in at 60 to have no payments
including a house payment and you have
assets you can sell I mean even though
you guys don't have a million bucks in
retirement you're in a good spot
financially especially because of that
pension so I would have some some hope
and confidence that you guys are not
going to be struggling in retirement but
I also like you mentioned be wise with
the money you have going forward for the
next few years and put it to work
yeah I sure appreciate your guys's time
and uh I will get on your website yeah
sure jump on there I don't want any
financial advisor spooking you from
jumping into the stock market uh
especially when it is a great time I
mean if it was real high he'd probably
say well now's not a good time
everything's real expensive let's wait
and see how it goes so I would just get
a second opinion and I love our Smart
Vista Pros they really do have the heart
of a teacher and they'll educate you
they're not going to make decisions on
your behalf they're just going to help
you be confident to make the right next
step right and they can speak to that
fear I think we've even seen that in
real estate market so some agents are
very fear driven some investment
professionals are fear driven and we
want somebody who's going to help you
feel peace around your finances peace
around your money because we make way
better decisions when we're not in fear
no one makes good decisions when they're
panicked or drunk so do it from a
peaceful place and your life will be
better for it give us a call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
slash Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Christina Ellis
this hour this is your show America give
us a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll talk about your
life and your money Joseph is up next in
Jacksonville Florida Joseph welcome to
the show
hey how are you today happy Monday
what's going on with you
uh I'm a 58 year old widower I have
three kids only one still at home with
me uh I have about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in savings maybe
another 70 and uh my 401k and I have
about 52 000 on my mortgage
I just found out today at 11 A.M that I
lost my job oh my goodness
should I pay off my mortgage or should I
just go month to month hoping I find a
new job I was really hoping to be I was
hoping to be debt free in three to five
years well what were you doing hanging
on to the 150k in cash
uh in all honesty I just got about half
of that because my mom passed away oh
I'm so sorry
man life has just been happening to you
uh the last three years have been brutal
I lost my wife I lost the niece and a
nephew I lost my mom I lost my dad
I'm so sorry how long did you have this
job for
10 years wow what kind of work were you
doing
I.T okay
well obviously right now I mean it's so
fresh I think we have to grieve have you
even taken time to grieve everything
you've lost over the last few years so
you've just been going hard man taking
care of the kids and just going to work
doing what has to be done
yes ah Joseph
I'm so sorry brother
well I think A1 is to take care of
Joseph because you're in a great
financial position to be truthful with
you I mean you've got plenty of an
emergency fund to get you by I don't
know who wouldn't hire a sharp I.T guy
who has that many years of experience
especially in today's world there's a
desperate need in that field
and you've set yourself up for a time
like this where you don't have to worry
about money and you can worry about
Joseph instead
you said you've got one kid living with
you
yes do you know your monthly expenses
he turns 17 in November okay
and he still is in school working
yeah he's still in school okay uh and
I'll be honest you know since I found
out 11 A.M this morning
I've been trying to cut every monthly
expense and I can yeah I've cut the pull
guy I've got the yard guy I've cut piano
lessons for my son
I've cut the gym that he was a member of
well Joseph the good news is I know I
never I never thought I would find
myself in this position yeah no one no
one does
but the good news is you have an
emergency fund and it's there to cover
Times Like These when life hits you
you're covered and you can cover the gym
membership still
you can cover the piano lessons and
Joseph you sound like a doer you said
you have your goal of paying off the
mortgage immediately whenever you found
out at 11 you're going into action
trying to cut things and figure things
out but I do encourage you like George
said just to take some time
before 11 my plan was three to five
years
but after 11 I don't know but I hear
what you're saying and I think it's okay
not to know right now I think it's okay
to give yourself permission to take a
little pause to not take action to to
give yourself Grace on that for three to
five years to just take a moment to
breathe like you have been through it
you have been through some serious life
and this is a moment you have the
finances you've been saving diligently
you're going to save diligently you're
going to get to a spot again where you
can reach that goal but right now
take that space
take that space to just sit in it work
through it re rethink through you know
what life looks like right now
um because yeah you're going through a
lot what are your views on counseling
and therapy Joseph have you ever been
open to that looked into it
uh uh if I have to be honest no I'm not
very open to it
uh
and why is that
foreign
well the truth is we can change it
anytime we have seen folks who are 70 do
their debt free scream
because they decided to change and they
thought it was too late and we gave them
a little bit of Hope and they did the
hard work and they transformed because
of it and so I want to encourage you
that it's definitely not too late for
you
you could live another 30 years God is
God is good and I know that and I know
what he has in store for me is probably
better than I can imagine absolutely yes
and amen but and God also gave us real
wise people in our world like counselors
and therapists who can walk us through
the tragedies of Life the hard stuff and
help us grow and a lot of the times the
times that we grow when we transform is
because of someone else stepping into
our life someone giving us an
opportunity someone coaching us someone
helping us through trauma and I'm going
to gift you John deloney's book own your
past change your future we're going to
send that book to you because I think
hopefully that at least opens your heart
a little bit to the idea of counseling
but I would strongly encourage you take
some of that hundred fifty thousand
dollars and you put a little bit of
money and invest into yourself right now
because you've invested everywhere else
into your kids into your financial life
but rarely into Joseph
well and I encourage you to watch the Dr
John deloney show just even listen to
some of the other calls where people are
going through grief and listen to how he
counsels them if you're not quite ready
to go to a counselor yourself just being
able to listen and hear other people and
how they're working through it could
really help inspire you yeah so Joseph
to answer your question so so don't pay
off the mortgage immediately
deal with me deal with my kids deal with
the grief exactly and the money's still
going to be sitting there you can put it
in a high yield savings account if it's
not already
where is it just in your checking
account your savings connected to that
savings and Credit Unions yes okay
well it can grow at you know probably
two and a half percent right now with a
with a good high yield savings account
online if you want to do that while you
just stay put for now and when you're
ready maybe after maybe you take a month
off and just heal a little bit and then
we start looking at new IT jobs and
maybe you find a job that was even
better than one you had and you get paid
even more what were you making at your
old job
uh and my old job I was making 130 Grand
a year oh that's fantastic
why is that
just who I am did you think you just got
a monkey
in a way yeah I think maybe I did I
don't know I mean
I don't doubt God I mean God has proven
himself to me through the years but
I'm a stubborn person
well we can change that and uh again
it's not too late for you and we're
going to send you that copy of John
deloney's book own your past change your
future stay put where you're at right
now take a month don't make any rash
decisions and when you find that new job
go all right I got 150k in the bank and
the house is going to be paid off and
it's one less thing to worry about and
now I'm sleeping better what's your
mortgage payment
uh about 1200 a month well you're going
to get 1200 back in your life as soon as
that mortgage paid off
yeah and as you work through this
healing process I just encourage you to
speak life over yourself I mean I think
even in this call you said you know I'm
stubborn I'm not somebody who sees a
counselor I'm you know we all have those
voices in our head and those identities
that that we kind of just take ownership
of so I encourage you to kind of change
that script you know you are going to
find another great job you are going to
heal from this you are going to get
through this and I love to hear about
your faith and how you're you know you
know God's going to get you through this
but also you know believe in yourself
and keep speaking life over yourself
I think that stubbornness can actually
translate very well as you come out of
this season you know you're going to
stubbornly go I'm going to pay off this
house I'm going to get a job making 140.
I'm going to keep building this career
and that confidence will will take you
places man if anyone talked to Joseph
the way Joseph talked to Joseph you
would be angry at that person and say
you don't talk to Joseph like that right
he's a good guy he works already takes
care of his family he's been through a
lot and uh I think it's it's hard
sometimes to get rid of that negative
self-talk and step into what we were
called to do so Joseph we're cheering
you on I hope Dr John deloney's book
helps you hang on the line Austin will
pick up we'll make sure to send you a
copy of that and we're wishing you the
best my friend this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well we know a lot of you are scared
right now between inflation and debt
payments you feel like you're drowning
and you're terrified you won't have
enough to take care of your family
but you shouldn't have to live in fear
but you have to get to the point where
you say I've had it and then decide
you're ready to make a change because
you can't keep doing the same things
with money and expect different results
and that means it's time to try
something new and that thing is
Financial Peace University this is the
course that will teach you the proven
step-by-step plan that's helped nearly
10 million people beat debt Master
budgeting and build wealth and you can
do this too
guys stop letting debt and money stress
control your life say I've had it and
take back your control start Financial
Peace University at ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU open phones this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk your life and
your money Lacey joins us up next in
Atlanta Lacey welcome to the show
hi thank you absolutely how can we help
today
okay so I have a question my husband and
I I have been following Dave's advice
religiously for about seven years I took
Financial Peace University at my church
when I was 29. awesome and yeah I know
it has been awesome it's gotten us to a
great place so we own a business our
business is debt free we are debt free
personally
um and we're ready to start investing we
have a Year's worth of um our bills in
savings and now we're past that point
and we've started saving for the kids
colleges
um we have many um invested and so the
next step is to continue investing and
I'm in real estate and my dream is to
have a cabin in North Georgia which is
like an hour from where we live and we
want to rent it out
um like as an investment property on
VRBO Airbnb that sort of thing and so we
would only be cutting down about 20
percent which Dave would say not to do
that because
you were going into debt right but our
monthly
um
income
is on average about 11 to 12 000 a month
and our mortgage on our primary home
which is our only debt is about 1700.
so my question is if Dave you know under
his plan technically we could sell our
house
and buy a more expensive house and still
be within his plan
but why can't we take on the debt but
half of our mortgage payments would be
income producing
does that make sense yeah no I
understand you're making the analogy of
well if I got the rental property it
would be the same as if I had a bigger
mortgage
right but that would be income producing
yeah the difference is you it's not your
primary residence so you don't live
there and so it's up to another tenant
to hopefully produce that income your
primary residence doesn't produce any
income it's just for you guys right so
what's left on your mortgage
um while we owe about 250
000 but it's worth significantly more
because we bought in early 2020 and then
prices shot up and also we've put a lot
of money into it which we've been
Finance anything we paid cash so we've
increased the value that way as well
how much is it worth now
um it's worth probably between for
around 475 I would say
well one thing is for real estate agents
it's easy to get Starry Eyed when it
comes to real estate of course you love
real estate
right and I understand it right and so
now that I can invest more I would
rather invest in real estate because I
understand it and it's a tangible asset
rather than put my money in the stock
market because
um I don't understand the stock market A
and B everybody around me keeps talking
about losing money and see my parents
are baby steps Millionaires and they
have a significant amount of money in
the stock market that's going to be left
to us because they are living off of
their pension and their social security
so I feel like I'm already invested in
the stock market in a way
okay well
you you said you follow our stuff
religiously but it sounds like you guys
did the 30-year mortgage on that house
right
well that that is true so thank you one
point for George boom
so Lacy
that's fine I mean
you make great income this is not about
the math at this point and you can map
your way into all kinds of decisions all
day long
our plan is about peace
and right as I'm looking down I'm going
you guys made 12K a month and you're
still hanging on to a mortgage for fun
what are we doing here pay off pay off
that mortgage and how quickly could you
then save up and pay cash for this new
property
and have that be the dream and then
you're not worried about tenants I would
be like 50 I feel like oh and I paid off
250 000 and then save up another 250
000. how old are you and put my children
through college
how old are you guys how uh I'm I'm 36
and he is
um
41 but also okay there's there's an
added benefit it's like making memories
in the country away from technology in
the mountains you can do that without
buying a rental property while having a
mortgage yeah you can use Airbnb and
VRBO be the renter for that oh Lacey
Lacey Lacey listen if you called to
justify your decisions you're not going
to get that from us is this going to
tank you guys financially no you will
live to see another day you're gonna be
just fine you mentioned you've got
inheritance and you're worried about the
stock market I would encourage you to
learn about the stock market and have
that be a piece of the puzzle to
diversify your portfolio a bit because
as we've seen sometimes when the stock
market's down real estate's up there can
be some interesting relationships there
but no I I can't in good faith tell you
to go get another mortgage while you
have your mortgage and you guys make
great money you're just not making great
use of it and like I said our plan is
about peace and when you've got a paid
for primary residence and then you
invest with property using cash it
changes the game it changes everything
right well and you're mentioning putting
20 down on this new property throw that
20 towards your current mortgage you
also said you have a year a Year's worth
of bills again not not something we
would tell I mean six months Max is
enough for you guys right so I think
just taking some of that and throwing it
towards your primary residence you're
going to see some big project progress
fast and start that momentum and then
with your income you guys do have quite
a good income right now and I know it
sounds intimidating but I don't think
it's going to be 50 before you can pay
it off and before you can get a new
property take home it's not going to
take 14 years I mean we see people all
the time on the debt-free stage paying
off houses in a much mucher quicker time
much quicker time span so I believe you
can do this a lot quicker and still
fulfill that dream of investing in real
estate yeah so you can do Lacey's plan
and you guys will truthfully you're
gonna be okay I'm not that worried about
you guys you have a fantastic income you
have some decent money principles going
on here you've got the inheritance but
if you want to do it our way with a lot
more peace and a lot less risk that's
what I'd tell you to do go low and slow
like a crock pot that's the way to do it
all right let's take a uh well I don't
know if we have time for Benny we'll
have to wait for Benny for the next hour
Christina I'm sorry I need to do that to
him be the tortoise I think especially
right now with you know inflation and
money being tight in people's budgets I
think there's a lot of different
opportunities for people to try to use
kind of financial trickery they see they
see the numbers and they see the money
and things are flashier and they're
cooler and it looks like you can make
progress faster but we just encourage
you to be willing to use God in
Grandma's ways of doing money may not be
the flashiest thing but some of these
principles while they're not the
quickest they work oh yeah they work and
me and my wife we were on the the
debt-free stage uh back in January doing
our debt-free screen for paying off our
house and there's just nothing like it
and you know people even financial
advisors I would talk to and they're
like dude you're an idiot why would you
pay after you could have invested in the
market they could have been and it could
have it could have it could have is the
key word there could
cut but I can tell you we have no
mortgage payment that's a you know
that's a definitive statement when you
can sit in your paid for house and go
there's no Goods there's no risk here
you didn't have no payments and you
can't really put a number on that a lot
of it is emotional and mental and
spiritual and you can math your way into
all of these decisions all day long but
when you decide to do something so
counter-cultural and so different and
challenge yourself to make that level of
sacrifice for that period of time it
changes your character right well it's
like you're you're aiming towards
something so much of money it's about
Behavior change not just head knowledge
and it's like when you have that goal
that you're working towards it just
provides a fire that you're not going to
have when you're just kind of hoping the
numbers are a little bit more strategic
amen good word good hour Christina that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Austin and Ben and
James and Zach and Andrew in the booth
my co-host Christina Ellis and you
America we thank you for listening we
will be back with you before you know it
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell host of
the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined by best-selling author
Christina Ellis this hour and we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about life money debt payoff
budgeting Building Wealth and so much
more Benny is kicking us off this hour
in Seattle Benny welcome to the show
hi there uh long time listener first
time caller thanks for having me
listening and calling yeah welcome
what's going on with you
hey so
um my question is is we uh borrowed some
money from my annuity
a couple years back
um put down on a house we had the 10 but
we wanted the 20 to avoid the mortgage
insurance
and so now uh we have we're about
halfway through that we got about 18 500
left to pay off
and uh we're kind of wondering if we
should pay it off so we got
about
50 some thousand dollars in savings
right now
and uh so we could pay it off in full
but with the market right now we're kind
of like
hesitant because
it's just not doing really well and so
that's where the money would end up
going and we get like five percent right
now
on this money that we're paying monthly
back to that loan that will create a
monthly
income
well yeah so the annuity is just for
when I retire
um why did you jump into the annuity to
begin with
well uh so my annuity is from my work so
it's through my job I get uh an hourly
amount of money put towards it it comes
to about eleven hundred dollars a month
okay so if you paid this 18.5 today what
would it do for you financially
um it would just go into that annuity
account and
um we'll find out start to lose money
um but like I said we listened to the
show and and you guys are pretty adamant
about putting that money into the market
even though it's
it's not doing well right now yeah it's
similar to borrowing against your 401k
correct right okay yes so if this was a
401k loan we would say go ahead and pay
it off today regardless of what the
Market's doing and so you've got 50k I
mean that still leaves you with what
31.5 in cash
right and that's your emergency fund and
plus a little more
so yeah uh we have 35 000 in our
emergency fund oh that's seven thousand
and savings and four four thousand and
checking okay that was that's what makes
up the 50K
right yeah
I'm paying off that uh the annuity loan
today I'm being done with that and if
you need to restock a little bit to get
you back to a good place uh with the
emergency fund which it doesn't sound
like it should it sounds like you should
still have plenty for three to six
months of expenses
right yeah I mean it it's just we're
like
with our budget right now we aren't
quite making it and we're trying to cut
uh some Corners you know and and is it
an income problem or is it an expense
problem
it it's kind of it's an income problem
uh right now my wife she she
lost her job and she just got a new one
back but we've been living in the red
for probably about four months now and
have you been surviving dig into our
city
well just off of my money and our
savings I mean uh the money that I've
been getting paid monthly okay with our
bills or or probably about 1200 in in
the red right now so we're trying to but
you're not touching debt to do that
you're just draining your savings
essentially to survive yes okay and with
your wife's new job will your income be
right back at a spot where you can
afford your payments you can afford your
budget
um I think it's it's going to put us
closer if we can get this paid off
um
I just we we just got a few more things
we're gonna have to to carve out but
this is the big one and this is the one
we just aren't sure about you know it's
it's kind of scary and the testing or
throwing money in and watching it just
go go down but it's also kind of scary
feeling like you owe something like I
can feel the weight and the heaviness in
your voice like that's one of the things
like with this payment I have to make
towards this it feels kind of you know
heavy we can't really afford that so
it's like at least getting that out of
your life now and finishing with that
18.5 that's done and then you can focus
on rebuilding that stuff is that all the
debt you have is the 18.5
no it's not
um so we have uh a solar loan oh man it
is
115. come on
what was the total loan you took out for
that
it was like 37 000. I wonder you guys
are feeling tight you got payments
everywhere what else do you have
well all our vehicles are paid off okay
um so we don't have any of those we just
have our mortgage that's about three
grand oh man that's high what's your
take-home pay
so um after taxes I make about 1800 a
week
okay but with your wife's new job what's
what's your new household take-home pay
um
so yeah we're probably going to be
probably around 400 more so you're
probably looking at like 20 2200 a month
or a week yeah okay so at 2200 a week
that puts you guys at let's see
about 114 take-home pay does that sound
about right
that sounds about right yep okay
so the issue I'm seeing here is that's a
you've got quite a hefty mortgage even
compared to your take-home pay
right because you split That Into You
Know 3K into 9 500 which is what your
monthly take-home pay and you're talking
32 now that's not the only thing that's
stealing from your paycheck here it's
also the solar loan and the annuity and
all these different things and so I'm
going to put you guys on to every dollar
premium so that you guys can start to do
a monthly written budget uh you can use
the app you can do it online and I want
you to do this together as a couple and
once you do that and everything is
listed income minus expenses equal zero
go through every expense and go are we
doing as best as we can on this expense
can we cut it can we do our research can
we get this insurance premium down can
we cut eating out this month right now
you guys have to find that traction and
get back in the black
would you agree
yeah totally well I I hope that helps
Benny I know things are tight right now
and that's one of the things that makes
me so angry about debt is you look up
and you go we're making great money
where is it all going and it's going to
lenders so they can make big buildings
and sponsor stadiums while you're over
here wondering how you're going to put
food on the table next week so let's get
all of this debt out of our Lives the
solar is next and then later on we can
deal with the mortgage but hang on the
line Austin's gonna pick up we're gonna
gift you one year of every dollar
premium as well as Financial Peace
University our nine uh lesson course
that you can watch with your wife to get
fired up but getting out of debt and
Building Wealth thanks for the call
Benny this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour this is the Ramsay show
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money Houston Texas is where we go next
Matt joins us there Matt welcome to the
show
hi hey how you doing got a question good
good good got a question thank you for
taking my call absolutely uh my mother
recently passed away oh sorry to hear
that and well thank you uh and my
siblings and I are
going through the process of
going through her IRAs and cash and
after it's all said and done I stand to
inherit around
around ninety thousand dollars okay
around 72 000 of that is going to be in
an IRA
um
in a 401k and I have been advised
to open up and the inherited IRA aspect
my question is should I take that Ira
that I'm inheriting and cash it out and
pay off my mortgage or should I take
the required minimum distribution
over several years for the for the taxes
I'm just I'm very confused about how to
do this
now is this a traditional IRA or was it
a Roth yeah both for a traditional okay
yes sir and have you looked into the tax
implications of cashing this out
well I I from my understanding it's
going to be at my tax rate which is 24
okay
and so factoring that in are you able to
pay off the house
just about what's left in the morning
maybe I'm sorry what's left on the
mortgage
uh 74 000. okay and I have about four I
have about four years left on that
mortgage
do you have any other debts
no and fully funded emergency fund
I have I have almost but I but with the
cash that's coming from The Inheritance
as well I planned on even cushioning the
emergency fund
yeah yeah I mean I know my plan if I'm
in your shoes
and I'm gonna fill up that emergency
fund and use the rest to pay off the
house
and and take the initial hit on the
taxes yeah right away
okay yeah you've done a really good job
with your money the fact that you have
no other debt and that this inheritance
could wipe out your mortgage I mean very
close to wipe out your mortgage is is
amazing and personally I mean it's
obviously not the most ideal way to get
money that is so sad but also it's just
an amazing way to honor your mother to
have that leave leave that Legacy with
that money where you wipe out your
mortgage your debt free after that
that's what I'm doing that's a great
place to be and I still would talk to a
Tax Advisor anytime you have a big chunk
of money coming in there's a few people
I want to make sure I talk to and get
some second and third opinions one is a
tax Pro and another is a financial
advisor and so you can reach out to both
of those at ramsaysolutions.com we've
got tax Pros we've got smartvestor pros
on the investing side
and I'd walk through your plan with them
and see what they think about it but on
my end other than the tax uh
implications this is going to be worth
it because you're not having to pay your
mortgage anymore you're going to be
saving on the interest you're paying on
that mortgage so there's a lot of
benefits to that and now you can use
that money instead towards Building
Wealth
okay that's that's kind of the way I was
leaning I was just I I got saw that tax
bill and I thought oh gosh
definitely keep that money set aside for
to come tax time don't go do anything
rash with it but as long as the money's
there I mean it's not like there's a you
you have this money coming in from the
IRAs and so it's not really like you're
having a pony up yourself it's just
gonna they're taking a cut and they're
going to anyways eventually yeah yeah so
I mean that's sort of what I'm looking
at they're either going to get it all up
front or they're going to get it
incrementally when I have to take it out
exactly
so that's what I'm doing I mean it's
going to set you up for Freedom a lot
faster so I I see this as a as a huge
blessing and an incredible Legacy left
all right well thank you very much I
appreciate it yeah I appreciate the call
Matt all right Zach is up next in
Richmond Virginia Zach welcome to the
show
hello hey thank you very much for having
me on yeah what's going on with you
so my question is I am a recent college
graduate who um has a recently paying
full-time job at 62k a year and I also
have
um still a car loan and student loan
debts of about 45 000 and my question is
what should I do as far as my finances
over the next couple years to get those
paid off and should I invest in
retirement already and so on sure how
old did you say you were
22 22 making 62k what kind of work are
you in
uh financial analyst oh cool okay so
you're a numbers guy
right you got to stare at numbers all
day long which means you you know how
this works with your debt and your
interest and your paychecks this is not
anything new to you
that is correct are you currently on a
budget
um I don't have a personal budget but I
do use the rocket money app uh formerly
true bill to track my spending and
income okay well the so I you know I've
used those apps in the past before I
knew Dave I was like well I'm doing
great because I'm tracking it the
problem is when you don't plan for it up
front you're just seeing what happened
you're just looking at the past instead
of actually planning for the future and
sticking to it so I'm going to do you a
favor and gift you one year of every
dollar premium so that you can begin to
make a plan for that money as well as
track it and the goal is to stay within
your your budget categories and it
usually takes people about three months
to dial this in but what happens is you
start to pay attention to where every
dollar is going and you start to get
angry and go why am I spending so much
money oh my gosh I'm just bleeding out
in this area eating out I need to cut
back on that and so I think that will
help you make a plan for every one of
these dollars coming in so how many
debts do you have if you parse them all
out
my student loans break into like 17
different ones other than that it's just
a car loan and a revolving credit card
that I pay off every month okay so step
number one if you want to join the club
of weirdos you got to cut up the card
does that bother you
um could you stick to a debit card
yeah I really only use it for the cash
back I don't know I treat it like a
debit card already what's the cash back
on there
two percent okay on everything what if I
told you by doing a budget you're going
to give yourself two percent cash back
by making wiser decisions would you
believe me
because that two percent I mean how much
how much are you really spending a year
making 62k
that you're putting on the card
um
uh that's a great question maybe maybe
twenty thousand dollars
that's if you're going crazy 20 grand on
the card
sound fair
yeah it's probably what two hundred
dollars that's 400 if you get two
percent cash back that's 100 Grand 100 I
could make you 400 bucks easier this
month just by with wise spending and and
side hustles so if you're willing to go
and be that crazy cut up the card use a
debit card and list out your debts from
smallest to largest and then we're going
to attack the little one first so that
smallest student loan is probably what a
grand
mm-hmm and so that one's gonna get
knocked out quick
do you have any money in the bank
I've got about six thousand oh awesome
well this gives us a head start
and again part of this plan is doing
some weird stuff and so baby step one is
a thousand dollar starter emergency fund
you have that but that means the rest of
that 5000 would go towards those student
loans and probably knock out the first
few Bunch right
I also might be able to take advantage
of the Biden Administration student loan
forgiveness we'll see if that actually
happens sure
yeah we wouldn't necessarily count on
that but if we should know soon they're
supposed to they said by next week
October 17th we should have a little bit
more information but they said but they
also said the beginning of the month so
it keeps getting pushed back TBD feels
like your dad being like son we're gonna
I'm gonna take you to Disney it's not
banking on that at any point
sure well I did this uh 30-day trial an
older woman called in uh maybe about a
month or two ago and she did a 30-day
trial she believes he said I'm gonna try
using a debit card instead of my credit
card and see if it changes my money
Behavior at all and she called us back
and she said you'll never believe it I
saved so much money by not using the
credit card and part of it was the
psychology of that cash back and part of
it was it's my money and I'm gonna treat
it differently than someone else's money
and so I'm I'm rooting for you Zach hang
on the line we're going to gift you one
year of every dollar premium and we'll
throw in Financial Peace University to
give you uh the exact plan you need to
do to get rid of this debt and finally
start building real wealth but man at 22
making 62k You're Gonna Knock this debt
out call us back and maybe you can do a
debt-free screen that'd be fun this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at appliance.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
they are the number one online retailer
of custom window covering you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from JC in Utah my wife and I are on
baby step two with 148 thousand dollars
in debt my wife who uses a wheelchair
works from home and we have a nanny that
takes care of our children while she's
working after reading Total Money
Makeover and listening to the podcast
I'm fired up and ready to knock this
debt out my wife is not a hundred
percent on board and would like me to be
less intense with a little time for
herself she's enjoys splurging on
takeout and designer coffee and she
thinks ordering take out one to two
times a week is okay we use every dollar
and can budget for these expenses but I
keep hearing you in my head saying
sacrifice part of the challenge is I've
done FPU and she hasn't should I slow
down and and wait until we are on the
same page or keep pushing on my own oh
that's tricky yeah this is a lot more
relational than it is financial we don't
have a lot of numbers here other than
they have a giant pile of debt at 148
thousand dollars no clue how much they
make it could be 60 it could be 300. but
it doesn't matter because the point of
this is that his wife is not on board
she hasn't on fbu she doesn't get it
right and we don't know how these
conversations have gone so far so has
you know has JC come in with a really
honest and upfront conversation that was
calm and rational or has it been kind of
whiny and Naggy that's kind of hard
because Dave said we got out there you
can't eat and now his wife sees Dave's
name as a cuss word
yeah we often recommend you know you
want this to be an adventure and an
exciting thing and you know a lot of
times somebody one spouse gets so on
board and they're just like yes and they
go so hard that they kind of scare off
the other spouse oh yeah don't do that
Pro tip guys never never use that
approach of
going through a few by yourself first of
all because then they have no idea what
you're talking about and you're just
coming in yelling got to be exhale
intense Dave said we can't eat out
that's not gonna work and so JC number
one get her to go through FPU with you
if she's unwilling to do that it tells
me there's probably some deeper marital
problems here that may require some
counseling to go hey we can't even talk
about money without it being a blow up
fight and this is a deeper issue yeah
and I mean women tend to be wired for
relationships and security so you know
come at that conversation with you know
your heart for helping secure the family
finances for the future I mean 148 000
in debt that's a lot of debt that really
puts you guys in a vulnerable position
so I just think you could frame that
conversation in a way that really speaks
to her heart but lets her know hey I'm
not just trying to do this to make you
give up your coffees and take out I'm
not just trying to make your life
inconvenient I'm trying to do this
because I see a vision for our future
where we're not carrying around this
massive debt and we're not stressed out
and our children can have that security
and we can leave them a legacy like try
try to kind of reframing the
conversation in a way that really speaks
to her heart and just encourages her
yeah and what I'm saying here is she
would like me to be less intense well
the other side of intensity is
complacency
and that's not somewhere we need to hang
out very long because that is how we got
into 148k in debt in the first place is
just kind of wandering through our
financial life and just we'll worry
about hey that's a that's a future
George problem they don't need to worry
about that right now and so my guess is
she's not very involved in finances at
all because someone here is stressed and
it sounds like it's JC because he's been
crunching the numbers going 148
000 in payments adds up to thousands of
dollars a month and we can scrape by
right now probably because they have a
great income if they can afford a nanny
and take out and coffee I mean that's
the American dream right there but the
problem is this is designed to a
nightmare designer coffee I've never
heard of that term
so the question he asked was should I
slow down and wait until we're on the
same page or keep pushing on my own I
don't think you should slow down I do
think you need to be on the same page
because pushing on your own is just
going to push you guys further apart and
you're gonna have so much resentment
towards her because you're over here
busting your butt and she's just
drinking her designer coffees and
getting takeout
well and she's probably getting yelled
at and getting you know kind of the
brunt of the you know you're holding us
back and this is not moving forward
because because
um and so yeah really taking that time
to get on the same page yes
so so important I think you you know
what to do it's just not going to be
easy to have these conversations and get
somewhere and part of that is she's got
to understand this shared common
language that you learned in Financial
Peace University that gave you this
Vision that you now have to get out of
debt with what we call Gazelle intensity
so she's got to do that as the
foundation here if we're going to get
anywhere good luck my man that's not an
easy situation
all right open phones this hour at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Christina last week you co-hosted
with Rachel Cruz and you guys got a wild
call yeah it started to kind of make
some waves out there can you fill in the
listeners on what the heck happened yeah
we got a bit of a wild call somebody
called in he has a fiance in Columbia
whose mom has cancer and needs surgery
and we asked him how much money he had
he had fifty thousand dollars in the
bank and it just so happened that that's
the exact amount that they needed for
her cancer treatments and surgery so it
was a really kind of tricky call to
navigate because he sounded pretty in
love with this fiance
um and at the same time it kind of
sounded like a scam so we talked him
through it just kind of walked through
it but we didn't call him out for the
scam part on air but we did call him
afterwards to talk to him oh I did not
know this find out a little bit more
information and just let him know that
this could potentially be a thing so he
has actually met the person several
times he's been down there she's real
she is real but at the same time he does
feel pretty hesitant about sending the
money he doesn't really know about the
mom and if if her situation is really
legit she is you know she does have
health challenges
um but could also see her taking
advantage of money but the more I've
explored this the more that we've you
know really seen that this is a huge
thing this world of dating scams it's a
thing I've talked to other people in
coaching calls and in situations where
people have been scammed by people
um who are just trying to get their
money and I think it's hard right now
because on one hand there are people out
there who are desperate for money and
then on the other hand coming out of the
pandemic there are people who are really
desperate for love oh my goodness and
they want that connection and they want
you know they want to feel like someone
loves them back so it makes them
vulnerable for scams so I want to
quickly call out a few potential scams
that are pretty common right now okay
good make sure listeners don't fall for
it yeah so there is an airfare scam
where you meet this person online and
and they're lovely and they're from a
different country and all they need is x
amount of money for you to bring them to
the United States to me that's the way
you do it so you send the money for
airfare and then they go oh shoot
there's an extra expense for the Visa
can you send that too and before you
know you're roped up and do a lot of
money and you get kind of desperate
because you're like this is my chance to
meet the love of my life
I need to bring them here so that's one
the sudden emergency which could
potentially have been the situation last
week where it's like you know there's a
medical crisis there's some type of
issue with the family where someone
needs you know money to get out of jail
which that would be kind of shady but
there's some big thing that they need
this money right away or there's just
the the typical expenses like I'd like
for you to buy me jewelry or pay for
expenses but they're they're really good
nowadays reading some of the examples
and hearing from different stories
they're pretty scammers are super
manipulative they may not even be able
to catch I think I think a lot of people
think like I would know it I would be
able to sniff this out but they I mean
they're pretty sophisticated so just a
few important mentions if you're
potentially in a situation like that are
you talking to somebody who's in a
situation like that you know one of the
biggest things is don't share your
personal info they do not need to know
your address they don't need to know you
know your family's information your
social security number anything that
they can do to kind of put you in an
interesting situation be really careful
with sharing that information and then
biggest thing sending money is off
limits like especially if you've never
met this person in person if this is
somebody who you know you've just
chatted with online or if you've only
met them online potentially you've met
them in a Google Hangout which I guess
is a really popular place where kids are
hanging out these days wow yeah but I
thought Google Hangout died a long time
ago with Myspace oh my goodness but also
be careful for keywords like things like
fate and destiny like things that'll
make you convinced that this is the love
of your life and they're all in yikes
those are kind of like a little bit of
the like uh-oh hot button Works anything
with emotion and Desperation I'm gonna
go red flag red flag oh maybe we
shouldn't venmo this person four
thousand dollars or Zell that's a big
one that was a tricky one there's a lot
of different scams out there y'all so be
careful safe out there people and get ID
Theft Protection by the way yeah that's
a huge one uh our friends at Xander
offered it's super cheap and man I've
had that I've had that happen to me not
the whole catfishing dating thing but
just identity theft and it is a terrible
terrible situation well thanks for the
info Christina glad we got back in touch
with him this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guys right now you're hearing a lot of
Talking Heads in the news stirring up
fear about the real estate market and if
you believe them you think the housing
market will crash it's going to be a
repeat of the 2008 housing crisis but
you're not hearing the truth and you
can't make decisions based on fear you
need the facts and here they are simply
put in 2008 there was a huge supply of
homes not enough buyer demand so home
prices dropped that's not what's
happening in today's market right now
there are half as many homes for sale
and twice as many buyers that means home
prices aren't gonna go down anytime soon
they're growing at a slower rate so you
guys have seen asking prices come down
and you're going oh my gosh it's a crash
no it was just inflated because it was
like at the height of Beanie Babies we
were all trying to sell the Beanie
Babies off at 200 a piece and now
they're coming back down to reality and
so that's what's happening values are
not going down from what they were
before so if you're ready to buy a
seller home you do not need to wait you
can still win in this market we've got
to work with an experienced real estate
agent
and we've done the hard work for you of
vetting agents who know your local
market and have the transactions to back
it up this is not Uncle Larry who just
got his license so if you want to
connect with a Ramsay trusted agent for
free go to ramseysolutions.com agent and
check out our endorsed local providers
program again that's ramseysolutions.com
agent open phones this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell Join This
Hour by Christina Ellis and Christian is
up next in Los Angeles Christian welcome
to the show
hi guys thanks for having me can you
hear me yeah yeah what's going on okay
so my question for you guys is that I
had recently started a new job about a
month ago I'm a vet assistant I've been
working in the field for 10 years and
that's all I've ever done now I'm
getting to the point where I'm realizing
that I'm just not happy in the field
anymore with what I'm doing that I kind
of want to start venturing out to go to
trade school specifically into like
medical coding
and I think my question for you is that
I currently don't have any debts I have
about a thousand dollars in savings
would it be a good idea just to leave
this current job and just go full time
into school because I do currently live
with my parents at the moment so and you
know they're perfectly okay with me kind
of taking a break from rent at the
moment right now
how long is this medical coding program
um it's about I believe eight to twelve
months I'm not mistaken
and do you know about
how much time it's going to take you a
week to do that
to do the program I'm assuming it's a
full-time program
right yeah I know that it's um Monday
through Thursdays for the classes are
the classes during the day or do they
offer an evening option
uh they are during the day
okay have you explored different schools
that maybe potentially have an evening
option where you could still keep that
full-time job
I have tried to look around before I
think the uh you know the biggest thing
for me is that I kind of want
I guess in a way like an out from the
field that I'm currently in
um so that's why I'm looking into maybe
just going to school full time so I
don't have to continue doing what I'm
doing and yeah and I've asked them
before two and part-time is an option
for what we do unfortunately so how much
are you making right now
uh do you mean per hour per year uh is
it hourly
yeah it is hourly okay what's the hourly
wage
uh about 17 17. okay so you're probably
looking at you're making about 34 Grand
yearly
gross pay roughly around that range okay
yeah are you open let's say okay you
want to be done being a vet assistant
are you open to doing something else
maybe you're a little bit more
passionate about while you still work
or while you go to school sorry
yeah and I have looked in that before
too I think the um the hardest part for
me unfortunately right now is trying to
really figure out um you know what other
options there are I'm currently 28 and
I've been only working in this field
since I was 17. so it is very hard to
kind of figure out what else there is to
do out there
um yeah if I'm in your shoes I'm
thinking I'm going to look into a
tuition assistance program I'm going to
see if there's any employer out there
that would pay me while I still go to
school not only pay me an hourly rate or
pay me a salary but also will help pay
for some of my schooling because I think
it's great if you can continue to work
while you're getting that trade school
program certificate and also it can help
you graduate debt free because that's
one of the biggest goals is we don't
want you to go into any debt while
you're paying for this program and also
it's great that you're you've got your
parents support because that's going to
be a nice spot you don't have to worry
about room and board or housing or
anything like that but what's the whole
program cost for the 12 months
um for the 12 months that I saw it was
about six grand okay and how did you
plan on paying for that
well I was going to try and find
part-time work in the meantime
um unfortunately it wouldn't be through
here to the current job that I met but
yeah it was uh you know I just wanted to
kind of get your guys opinion on the
situation because I know you guys would
probably recommend kind of saving up the
six grand and then paying it as I go
through the schooling
um yeah we definitely want you to cash
flow it it doesn't mean you have to have
it all tomorrow but you'd have to have a
great game plan to make sure we're not
going to have to touch debt to do this
have you talked to your parents about
this
I have as well
um they're very willing to pay the six
grand I unfortunately don't want them to
have to do that
um because they're both retired at the
moment are they in a financial spot to
do it
like do they want to be generous and
give this to you
yeah they are um totally capable of
doing it they're not um in any sort of
dead or like they're not going to put
them in a bind is what I'm saying
right yeah no definitely not so why not
allow them to be generous and cover your
schooling it's I mean six grand
comparatively to what most people would
pay for college is a dream if I'm a
parent I'm like yes absolutely
right and also there's the route of
scholarships like if you if you don't
want your parents to pay for it you also
don't want to work and save up the money
you could spend the next few months
applying for scholarships and trying to
get it that way just in a quick search I
found several scholarships that are
people who for people who are trying to
do medical coding or get into the
medical field in some capacity
percentage did the homework for you
Christian there's no out now now I also
would look into doctors offices and
hospitals and working part-time there
even in an administrative role I almost
guarantee you could make 17 an hour
doing something like that that would
actually put you in kind of what Ken
would call the proximity principle
you're already around the field you want
to be in even around the people doing
medical coding have you thought about
that
I have actually found a few positions
that are for like entry-level medical
billing
um just to kind of get my foot in the
door and do something like you said
around it and maybe you do it you go I
hate this or are you doing go I love
this and I already have a connection and
now when I get to the program they're
already offering me a job
right that's how it works
yeah I talked to this uh this student
who just graduated at one of the
Building Wealth events he was in a crowd
and he came up and he said Christina
guess what he's like I went to work at a
hospital just taking like a basic
regular administrative job and they paid
for me to become a nurse like I use
their tuition assistance went completely
debt free still made money while I was
going to school now I have a nice
savings account a nice pile of money and
I went to school debt free and I'm
earning more money so it's kind of like
a win in all directions yeah that's
amazing it's amazing what happens when
you just do a little bit of research and
have a little bit of Hope but the
problem is there's so much pessimism in
this space of just like well applying
for scholarships isn't going to be worth
it I'll never be able to work enough to
cover school and so I'm just going to go
to this super expensive school and just
put it all on loans and I'll worry about
it later and my life's going to be way
better off for it right and we're seeing
that people are not happy with their
decision they're regretting it they're
angry they can't buy houses they can't
start families they don't feel like they
can get married because of their
financial position
yeah I mean we've heard some stories and
it's just really sad they were promised
a beautiful bright future and it'd be
easy to pay off the debt from the great
degree that they would get the great job
they'd get after graduation and it's a
lot harder afterwards and one of the
most vulnerable spots it's for people
going back to school a lot of people
think you know they're not happy in
their current job and if I just go back
to school it's going to fix my problems
it's going to make me feel better and
I'm not saying that's with this
situation but there are a lot of
emotions when you reach that spot where
you're unhappy in your career and you
want to go back so it's always super
important to one question if a degree is
really what you need to move forward and
to feel that change in your life and two
how are you going to do it debt free
like because a lot of people get in that
spot where it's like okay now I need to
get an education at all costs and it's
going to fix this whole life feel or
this unhappiness I feel and it might you
might be able to it might help with the
financial part of that it might help
with a career change but you really got
to take the time to do it well and do it
the right way and do it without debt
yeah I always hear Ken Coleman say is it
the right path is it the best path and a
lot of the times if you dig deep you've
really realize it's neither right I
don't know why I'm doing this I just
didn't like my job and so I thought
going to school would just buy me some
time to figure it out yeah that's a real
expensive way you might as well just go
to Europe and have a good time and just
Eat Pray Love instead of going into debt
to do this good conversation good hour
Christina that puts this hour in the
books my thanks to the gang in the booth
there Austin Ben James Zach and Andrew
and you America thanks so much for
listening we will be back with you
before you know it
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host Christina Ellis
joined by my co-host George Campbell
give us a call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five first up we have
Charles calling from Nashville Tennessee
right down the road hey Charles
welcome to the show hey how's it going
thank you good how can we help
hi so um I recently got married and uh
right before we had gotten married
um a few months ago we had gone through
the Financial Peace University and we
have a thousand dollars in savings and
we're trying to pay off some debts that
we have like a car and a camper but we
also for the past year have been
building a house we acquired some family
land and we've been trying to build a
house debt free for a year now we're
coming up close to having that house
built
um uh we need we're roughly about
fifteen thousand dollars away from
having it built that free but we're
trying to decide how much how much of
our money we should be putting into the
house or should we put more into into
paying off our debts
um and we just haven't quite quite
figured out we're kind of at a at a
standstill right now so walk me through
both scenarios so let's say you were
able to cash flow the rest of the 15K to
get the house built and you made minimum
payments on the car and camper
is that a feasible scenario
yes so that's actually what we're what
we've been doing uh for the past few
months okay I see it kind of like if you
were going to try to finish college debt
free I would say well finish college
debt free and then we'll attack the debt
because you're already knee-deep in this
thing there's no getting out
and so I'd rather you not go in debt
further and cash flow the rest of this
okay so that's my state go ahead and
hold off our debt and and build the
house debt free I mean I might sell the
camper if I mean are you guys using this
thing every week
or is this kind of a toy we live in it
we live oh you live in the camper until
but then the house is built while we're
built in the house yep and then we plan
on selling the camper after the house is
built and taking the profit from the
camper and trying to pay that towards
the car oh that's brilliant building it
on okay I like this plan what do you
think Christina do you all have a fully
funded emergency fund
we do not have fully funded we have um
we have a thousand dollars in savings um
we've kind of got a lot of different
incomes coming in uh well I'm I'm what I
call a jack of all trades so uh we
haven't quite gotten to fully funded
emergency fund but we do have a step
separate uh savings accounts for like
the businesses we have three different
businesses and we have saving accounts
for each business and then we have our
own personal account and our own
personal saving account for that okay
yeah because you guys are technically in
baby step two which you don't have a
fully funded emergency fund there but it
does make me a little bit nervous with
building a house if something goes wrong
oh yeah it's frightening you know I love
that you're building the house debt free
that's awesome but I do feel a little
bit nervous about like what if an
expense pops up that's a little bit more
what if you know just the contractor is
a little bit late and and they need to
get extra they're they're building
project a lot more expensive just having
that thought in mind that things could
change is there a builder's warranty on
this
um no there's not we're doing it by hand
uh my my family I come from a family of
custom home builders oh wow it's a
building the entire house yeah so it
sounds like this only went wrong
yeah you can fix something okay that
makes me feel a little better that he's
handy like that yeah I mean it's not an
ideal scenario I if I could have chosen
the order of when these things go it
would be let's wait till we're debt free
have a fully funded emergency fund and
then cash flow building a house but
because we're already here I think
that's your best case scenario is to
avoid the debt sell the camper get rid
of the car and then build that fully
funded emergency fund
okay all right that sounds like a pretty
good blow well that's gonna feel great
having a debt-free house I mean good job
on that being able to do as you go
that's that's awesome
well thank you for the call
way to go Charles all right we'd love to
see it yeah next up we have Jack calling
from Philadelphia Pennsylvania hey Jack
welcome to the show
hey there how you guys doing today
we're doing great how can we help
so I am uh 19 years old and I'm a
community college student so I am
graduating in the spring with my
associate's degree with zero debt good
job we like to hear that thank you yeah
thank you I've I paid for it all out of
pocket just through working part-time
jobs and I landed
um a job part-time work now it's about
20 hours a week and I'm graduating in
the spring like I said and I'm just I'm
afraid of taking on debt going into my
next two years of continuing my
education
um so I I just I don't know I need some
advice on what uh what to think about in
terms of taking out loans or working
more hours to save up more money to pay
for the next two years well I'm just
going to say up front you've done an
awesome job by not taking out debt thus
far let's keep debt off the table let's
let's not even say the word student
loans we're not doing that yeah okay
that sounds good okay well what kind of
part-time job do you have right now you
said you're working 20 hours I
yeah I work as an accounts receivable
clerk for uh one of the car dealerships
near where I work it's uh part-time I
make 15 an hour but if I was full-time
it would be 18 an hour so that's I'm
stuck on part-time because I'm a
full-time student obviously and I didn't
think that I'd be able to work full-time
and be you know do both of them and what
are you studying
business administration
okay what do you want to do at the end
of that
um something related to finance uh
business administration was just the
general one uh that I signed up for when
I first started going to school and then
I plan on having a minor in accounting
or finance and I'm taking classes for
that right now awesome well I love your
work ethic I love that your first
thought is to get that job and to start
saving up money and to not take out
student loan debt if I'm in your shoes
I'm thinking really strategically about
that that part-time job I'm going to
look at places that have tuition
assistance so I would think if I'm in
your shoes I'm looking for an employer
that's going to help pay for that last
two years hopefully pay for it 100 plus
allow me to build up a pile of cash and
what's cool is there's a lot of
different companies that are doing that
now I mean they may not be the most
glamorous jobs it may be retail and
maybe working in a restaurant but if it
allows you to get that business degree
debt free while also earning money and
gaining experience in some capacity it
can be a win on multiple levels
how do you feel about that do you have a
certain tie to you know a certain type
of work are you pretty open to it for if
it means debt-free College
you know that's that's a good question I
uh I have had I've had a job pretty much
ever since I was I'm 19 right now my
very first job I got when I was 14. so
I've worked a lot of uh manual labor odd
jobs things like that kind of my entire
life I've never worked retail
um and I've tried to stay away from that
but to be honest I hadn't really ever
thought about like a tuition imbursement
or reimbursement program I've really
never even looked into that so that's
something I could consider and even just
do it really strategically like retail
could be like your last option see if
you can find a great job at a business
that has tuition reimbursement and maybe
you could be an assistant manager maybe
you could you know do something that
helps you also Flex those business
muscles that when you graduate you have
experience to put on your resume that
you're proud about and that can actually
help you get that next job hey thanks
for looking forward I love your
motivation I love that I love it he's 19
and you're having these conversations
that's just awesome well thanks for the
call this is the Ramsey Show we'll be
right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
from Midland Michigan hey Bill welcome
to the show
hey how's it going
hey great how can we help
um so thanks for everything you guys do
I've got a question my wife and I are
debt free aside from the house and uh
we're on four five and six right now we
both own our own businesses and
um so we sold our previous house last
year and we were able to put everything
we made on that one onto our current one
and only had to take out a loan for
about sixty thousand dollars awesome and
um finally bought a 210 000 purchase
which was awesome and a huge blessing
but so
I feel like and I think that we can pay
off said house by December of this year
if we keep saving what we're saving
currently and
um talk to my wife about it we only go
to balance right now about
just over 49 000 on it because we've
been paying extra on it too and
um had a conversation with her the other
day laid it all out and shorter and she
was on board with it and she was just
like
she's like I understand where you're
coming from and it's cool and I'm on
board with it but I'd like to talk to my
dad first together just to make sure
it's a wise idea because her dad's a CPA
and I said all this prefacing the fact
that I respect my father-in-law a lot we
have a great relationship I respect his
opinion but he's also not necessarily
like
you know that that care kind of guy you
know like he buys he kind of like he's
bought like a car on loans every couple
years carries credit cards which tweets
their own like whatever but I feel like
we're on different levels of that idea
and so I was like well I'll talk to him
but I probably already know what he's
gonna say
and so we had the conversation and he
was like well I don't see the point of
paying off such a small loan with such a
small interest rate
and you could just save up cash I was
like well I feel like we could pause our
investing for a couple months in order
to do this
and then restart the process of that
he's like well I wouldn't invest right
now either because the Market's crap and
I was like well what would you do
goodness gracious you would you wouldn't
be at the house and you wouldn't invest
and he's like I just pile up cash I was
like but we we've done that and so
my question is what should we do the
conversation to football and politics
and you do you when it comes to money
now does your father-in-law pay your
bills does he pay your mortgage no okay
I just wanted to make sure and I'm right
there with you like I he has an opinion
but his opinion is not the final vote
yeah I can have deep respect for the man
I can love him same thing with my dad
you know we talk money and I get
frustrated and we change the subject
because we are not going to agree and I
say thank you for your opinion we are
not taking a poll at this time uh what's
for dinner you know and so I think
that's yeah
well my whole thing with it too is like
so there's a kind of a two-parter is
like yes it'll take out a lot of our
savings but we'll still have an
emergency fund left over if we wait till
December to do this because we'll have
at least five months of saving saved up
and then we'll be able to save that
money right back up plus then you know
the house payment every single month
yeah and we both own our own businesses
I'm my wife owns a CrossFit gym and I'm
a massage therapist so aside from
pandemics and what not ever happening
again like physically I don't know when
my last day of work's ever going to be
yeah you know and I make good money
right now so I'd rather get everything
paid off now while I make good money so
that later I don't have to worry about
that when I need to take a different job
that's a great mentality and on top of
that bill I would not pause investing so
if you're doing four five and six you're
investing 15 if you've got kids you're
putting some away for college and then
anything left over we're throwing at the
house so I do agree if you want to go
down to you know four month emergency
fund and put the rest on the house and
get this thing paid off man you're gonna
sleep better and your father-in-law
while probably a lovely person doesn't
get a vote when it comes to what you do
with your money so when you guys are so
close to the Finish Line like a December
payoff that is going to be a debt-free
house that you're going to keep for
years moving forward so that's just
going to let you walk on that freedom
and I think you're right as a business
owner that security that comes from
having no mortgage no payments in the
world it's just it's gonna change the
way you approach business it's going to
help you feel so much more free so yeah
I agree football maybe politics
I personally wouldn't I stay away from
all of that I stay away from both
honestly Sports politics I know very
little about either you'll stick to
money money but we might need some more
conversation topics George that's true
all right next up we have Dave calling
from Jupiter Florida hey Dave welcome to
the show
hey guys how you doing today we're doing
great how can we help
um I had a question about renters
insurance if that was uh something worth
purchasing one thousand percent get it
today
yeah what made you not want to get it a
lot of places required but it depends on
where you're renting
yeah well it's actually uh well it's not
for me personally my sister she lived on
uh she lived in Fort Myers uh of course
there was a hurricane I just blew
through there
um and so she's looking to uh locate
over here to the east coast of Florida
close to me and she's needing to rent
something and she's more so look I guess
I guess the
the owner of the house that she was
renting didn't have flood insurance
apparently there's a lot of people who
don't have flood insurance in Florida
um so it's new to me but she started
asking me about renters insurance and I
had no idea about renters insurance so I
figured I'd ask you guys for your advice
or even if that covers anything like
flood damage well most of them don't
you're going to need to add that onto
the renter's insurance and so you can
have her contact Xander insurance
through our website Ramsey Solutions and
she definitely needs renters insurance
today and it covers a ton I mean it for
sure will cover fire hail lightning
theft and vandalism Windstorm plumbing
system freezes a vehicle hits your house
someone gets hurt in the house it covers
all types of things and it's super cheap
I mean you're talking 10 to 20 bucks a
month for most most of these policies
now I don't know with Florida I know
it's been crazy with the hurricane and
floods and people can't get insurance
they're having to pay crazy crazy
amounts of money to get covered but it's
just part of the deal if you're going to
live in one of these you know areas that
are prone into flooding right definitely
get it yeah it's so important and that's
great that you're having that
conversation with her because there's a
lot of young people that have no clue
they get out there they get their
apartment they think that if that was
required it would be part of the year
they think their landlord's insurance
covers their stuff and it doesn't and
they've had this happen to uh as one of
his tenants way back in the day and
there was a fire and they said okay when
do we get our check for all of our stuff
and Dave's like
that's not how it works I legally can't
even do that and so they I mean it was a
hard stupid text they learned and a
really sad one to not have renters
insurance in place and so if you are
renter part of the deal is you get
renters insurance and a lot of you know
apartment complexes require it well when
I was renting and some landlords
should I feel like if you're a landlord
please require your renters to get it
because it protects you and of course
your tenants so this is a A1 you got to
get in place and our friends at Xander
can help you out and make sure they they
will shop independently all of the best
companies out there to find you the best
rate in your area so I highly recommend
doing that today yeah and having those
conversations it's so important I mean I
know you've talked a lot about insurance
and just doing a checkup overall I think
it's important it's a good call out to
just I mean renters insurance is
important but there's a lot of different
types of insurance that people need to
make sure that they have in their life
that they have it covered yeah it's not
it's not something that usually comes up
over like you know dinner it's every
hour right stock renters insurance well
we did a free five-day walk-through
called confidence in your coverage you
can sign up for that ramseysolutions.com
confidence and every day for five days
there's a three minute video from me and
I'm breaking down a different type of
insurance I promise you I at least
attempted jokes I mean it's insurance so
like I get it but if you if you don't
enjoy it you get your money back and the
check is going to be exactly worth what
you paid and it's zero dollars so
ramseysolutions.com confidence if you
want some weekend plans you can start to
tune into those videos Christina I know
that's what you're itching to do well
you don't often hear the word jokes and
insurance in the same sentence but if
anybody can make that work together it's
you I tried my hardest I'm like we need
to make money fun at all costs and if
that means me trying to make a dumb joke
that even gets your brain to go gosh
that joke was so dumb I feel like at
least you're paying attention
so if you need some entertainment around
Insurance y'all check it out there you
go we'll be right back this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show right
now is the time of year when it's make
or break when it comes to our goals
we're heading into the holiday season
and let's be real it's hard to stay
motivated we all have goals whether it's
to find a better job make more money pay
off debt build stronger relationships
and it can be hard to keep momentum
going but here's the good news coming up
in a couple weeks we have one of our
biggest events smart conference we're
headed to Dallas for a day-long
jam-packed event where you'll get advice
from leading experts on money personal
growth career mental health and your
marriage you'll leave with all the
knowledge and motivation you need to
reach your goals and live the life you
want to live join me and the rest of the
Ramsay personalities Dave Ramsey Dr John
deloney Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz George
to get a plan for your money
relationships and career growth join us
live in person on October 22nd to get
your passes before they sell out visit
ramseysolutions.com events to get your
tickets today I love it I love that I'm
like Madonna now I'm just George
I don't even need the last name you all
know you don't need further introduction
you don't even know well that's gonna be
a fun event I mean uh I have been to
many many of these and it is seriously
the most fun you can have at a very
insane price point for an all-day event
we've got a live band I'm gonna try to
join the band I'm going to audition live
at smart conference see if they'll
accept me in case my talk doesn't go
well but it's going to be a great time
it really is a great event to bring
someone who doesn't really know Ramsay
and you're like hey just get a taste of
everything they do yeah of the kind of
hope that we want to bring in every area
of your life from personal growth to
Career to mental health to money and it
really you it's like drinking from the
fire hose and you leave and you're
exhausted and you you're so on fire to
go change some areas for your life yeah
if you need a jolt of motivation come
see us in Dallas and just make the drive
make the flight whatever you got to do
Dallas is a great you know Central Point
for a lot of people to visit people come
from all over the world to these events
That's so exciting hey we're taking your
calls Triple eight eight two five five
two two five next up we have Monica
calling us from St Louis hey Monica
welcome to the show
um hello thanks for you guys having me
I'm so nervous okay um
it's just us we're just hanging out
having a conversation
oh okay okay
um I messed up real bad okay so
um
I bought a house
um it's not my primary residence I
actually bought a duplex where I stay on
one side and rent out the other
um I bought it in May I didn't listen to
you guys oh well today
Ramsey's show until uh June so uh they
said that you were opposed to Ashley uh
pay cash for investment I didn't know
that I actually just went ahead and
bought it and I thought I could do the
little hack where you know you stay on
one side and then the other side they
probably have enough to cover it didn't
go like that they actually uh they don't
pay enough to cover you know the whole
mortgage actually actually they're
really under work I didn't even raise
their rent because they just been there
for about 30 years now so I didn't even
bother to raise our rent so it's not
market price at all and um I feel like
I'm like stuck I want to like sell it
back
um and the lady that sold they helped me
the realtor she said if I sell it back
the most I would just probably break
even which is kind of okay with me you
know I don't mind I don't mind breaking
I just want to get it's not like a bad
area it's really a nice area you know to
do places it's one bedroom shotgun like
it's it's just I did the steps wrong I
just that's okay you know what that
means Monica it means you're over 12
years old if you've made a money mistake
and we've all been there and some people
do it with more zeros on the end and
it's okay
we're gonna learn from it we're not
going to make it again and honestly
breaking even is a best case scenario
for you A lot of people lose money on
these deals
okay and so what happens if you sell
this thing and you break even where does
that put you financially
now because I have my student loans I'm
going to pay off so it really wouldn't
do anything you know it wouldn't make me
or break me really I mean I don't okay
I'm just want to get out I just want to
get out the deal real bad would you have
to go find somewhere to rent
uh no no I have like I have my liver
situation everything is perfect okay
this deep place is just over my head
like oh my gosh it's horrible but um
well thank you from persuading all of
the people on Tick Tock out there who
are peddling this crap you got to do the
house hack man they pay your mortgage
for you you get rich so quick okay I was
listening to somebody else podcast I
can't mention his name but he was like
other people money and I'm like really I
can do that and it's nothing like that
it's it's not like that at all like
but um a lot of people need to hear that
today like you said it's so trendy right
now A lot of people are thinking that
they're going to be the one that gets
Rich doing this way and
they end up in that situation where you
hear the word house hacking just run so
Monica yes you're gonna you're gonna pay
that you're gonna sell that thing break
even and then we're gonna attack all of
your Consumer Debt from smallest to
largest using the debt snowball and just
leave a thousand dollars for that
starter emergency fund in the bank and
once you're debt free and you build up a
fully funded emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and then we can
start to invest and we can start to do
things the right way one at a time with
Focus intensity and Monica can be a real
estate investor later on in life when
she's at the place to do it and it's not
a stressor it's a blesser oh I like that
you like that she hated that it's okay
Christina I'll just let that hang there
all right next up we have Daniel calling
from San Bernardino California hey
Daniel welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me
um so I'm 21 years old um I just had a
baby she's currently three months year
old well congratulations
thank you thank you and um I'm having
trouble
um just financially um I owe 66 000 in
debt um I can't I try to monthly payment
I mean um I'm sorry uh budgeting and I'm
just having trouble budgeting me and my
girlfriend we're trying to do it on our
own and as well um we're also trying to
get out of my parents house we currently
pay rent and we pay rent for a one
bedroom that's it
all three of us just in one room so uh
it's kind of hard right now well it's it
doesn't sound like you've got a lot of
options as far as moving out and renting
your own place which is going to be more
expensive right
yeah
how much are you paying your parents in
rent right now
uh I pay my parents uh thousand dollars
a month right now okay okay
um how long have you tried budgeting you
said you tried it for a little bit
uh it's been about a total of like seven
to eight months six six to eight months
what are you using to budget
um just just my regular calculator just
figured my monthly expenses what I have
left over
and um yeah that's pretty much it really
okay I'm gonna gift you every dollar
which is our app it's online as well and
this should help you uh you can do this
on the go and it's digital and so your
girlfriend can look at this as well are
you guys combining finances I know it's
a tricky situation
since you've got a kid with your
girlfriend now
yeah we have our finances combined I'm
actually the only one working right now
okay what's your what's your income
I make about 75 annually okay great what
do you do
uh I'm a construction worker okay I work
on gas lines
and so your take-home pay I'm guessing
in California it's lower than other
areas do you know what your monthly
take-home pay is
yes it's currently this is
um if I live like with a little bit of
overtime but it's about 4 800 monthly
okay great and the rent is a thousand of
that and you've got a few other expenses
I imagine especially with a kid now
yes so how much is left over to tackle
the debt at the end of every month
uh let's see I can do the math really
fast
um
is it you know 500 bucks extra left over
that you can tackle the debt is that a
thousand
it's about yeah around six to eight
hundred okay what kind of debt is the 66
um I have thirty thousand dollars in
student loans six in credit cards six
thousand credit cards
um eighteen thousand in
um a car and then 13 000 is a personal
loan okay what's the car worth
I call him upside down that's currently
worth
uh 16 in my old 22 on it oh you said 18.
okay well that changes things okay hang
on the line Austin's gonna pick up we're
gonna gift you Financial Peace
University as well what I want you to do
is watch all nine lessons with your
girlfriend we're gonna send you every
dollar as well get on a written budget
every month shave down all the expenses
you can work all the overtime you can so
we can start tackling this debt more of
your calls coming up this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
4 23 Above All Else guard your heart for
it is the Wellspring of life
John Mark Comer says our time is our
life and our attention is the doorway to
our hearts oh so good I'm Christina
Ellis Ellis joined by George Campbell
this is the Ramsay show let's go to the
phones James calls us from Salt Lake
City Utah
hey James welcome to the show
hey guys
um so I'm on baby step two
I'm also trying to plan on saving up for
a wedding a couple weeks ago I bought a
ring
I saved up cash and bought it um good
and so I'm going to be asking her in the
next couple weeks
um congrats that's exciting are you
freaking out
kind of yeah but we're we're on the same
page financially good
um it's just so all I have left is a
five thousand five thousand dollars on a
car okay I will have it paid off by
March
um you know I've been getting gazelle
intense
just paid off all my credit cards a
couple weeks ago but um awesome I'm just
wondering so we're thinking of getting
married early summer
uh maybe late spring so you know around
April or May I'm just kind of worried if
like I get to the step where I I pay off
the car never going into debt ever again
um
I just wonder like I don't think two
months is fast enough to save up for
a wedding why is it all on you to pay
for a wedding
support
I don't not for certain I think we'll
get support from our from our folks but
I was just wondering like
I guess
once I figure out how much I would
contribute I'm just not sure if I'll
have enough time but
sure I guess if not I don't know have
you had this conversation with your
fiancee
yes yeah we're super open about this
okay how does she feel about it does she
feel that Financial stress or do you
truly feel like it's all on you
um now I think it's kind of on both of
us she has no debt
um she actually has a lot more money
than me she's a saver
and I've kind of gotten her onto the the
Ramsay thing but she's she's so good
about it anyways before I kind of went
into it a bunch so well an easy way to
look at it is however much money we have
is how much we can spend on a wedding
and that might mean making some
compromises some sacrifices we don't get
this venue we go to this venue we're
going to DIY the the centerpieces on the
tables there's a lot of things you can
do to shave costs down it doesn't need
to be the most extravagant party of all
time so that's how I like to look at it
because it when you take that off the
table you just start to get creative and
go okay we can't do a twenty thousand
dollar wedding we can do a seven
thousand dollar wedding what does that
look like
and I mean I know there's a lot of
social pressure a lot of people you've
probably been to a lot of weddings from
friends and you've had family members
have weddings and they may have an open
bar and a plated meal and all of that
you kind of feel that pressure to keep
up but it's your wedding it's your
finances you have worked so hard for
where you're at you're going to keep
working hard your fiance is out of debt
we want to keep you there so it's like
you got to just own where you are and if
it's not the most glamorous wedding
that's okay I mean me and my husband our
wedding was under five thousand dollars
we any person who was like Hey I'm
willing to help you you know set up for
your wedding I was like I will take it
yes I had people ironing out the
tablecloths I mean literally anybody who
offered to help I was like yes and sold
so absolutely yeah and worry about that
when the when the time comes you know
tomorrow's got its own trouble so let's
just focus on what we can do today which
is getting out of debt let's start to
build that emergency fund and as we get
close to the wedding we're gonna have
the conversations with family and go hey
here's what we're planning are you guys
able to contribute were you planning on
contributing and you might be shocked
and the parents go yeah we'll chip in
five grand we'll chip in five grand and
then she can ship in five grand you can
chip in however much you can contribute
yeah that's so good and so just the key
is stick to a budget make it reasonable
and don't get all Starry Eyed and go
well we need this four thousand dollar
arch of flowers that are gonna die four
hours later just it's the wedding
industry has gotten insane it's a whole
thing it's a whole thing next up we have
Dan calling from Charlottesville
Virginia hey Dan welcome to the show
hey Christina hey George how are y'all
great thanks for calling how can we help
good thing I had a question about paying
down the house I wanted to put this out
there in case anyone else been a similar
situation my wife and I are 31 with no
Consumer Debt or mortgages on a 15-year
fixed two and a half percent we're we're
on track to pay that off early awesome
uh before we knew how how aggressively
we wanted to pay that down we had a
chunk of money above our 20 our
emergency fund that we
decided to set aside for a few years uh
until we had clearer goals
um you know a pitch the house in case we
needed a car we started family since
then
um so it's it's been great having that
there but it's currently in a brokerage
account that was performing extremely
well until a short while ago but the
balance in that account and the balance
on the mortgage have been slowly ticking
closer to each other or they were
uh my question is this would you still
suggest Cashing Out non-retirement
mutual funds and you know taking a
twenty thousand dollar bath uh in the
name of debt Freedom or does it ever
make sense to delay paying off
non-consumer debts for 12 to 12 18
months so as to not secure the losses of
a bear Market it's a great question and
it's a hard one emotionally to Grapple
with when you're selling your shares you
know at a loss essentially I mean
obviously you guys have done well in
this account I'm guessing you know it's
well beyond your contributions right
oh yeah as far as the growth it's just
not as much as it was
and you're like man we could have sold
at the top yeah it's probably lost 20
I'm guessing
uh yeah how much is in there today
uh
uh
uh 65 I think and what's left on the
mortgage
uh about 120.
okay
so I mean they're they're far enough
away that I'm good with you continuing
to just pay uh down the mortgage with
your income what do you guys make
um before before side hustles uh just
north of 110. awesome and So currently
or you know outside of this brokerage
account how what was your debt payoff
goal for the house
uh you mean on uh timeline yeah was it
three four five years
well originally it was like 10 to 12
years and as we as we got closer and
just as as incomes Rose
um and just as you realize that
um you know we were we were in a pretty
good situation financially and and have
been just chunking extra on it every
month we've realized that uh you know
paying off
by the time we're like 35 or 37 is a
definite possibility you guys can do a
lot better than that I mean how much can
you throw a month at this mortgage
four grand
uh probably not that much
um but we're
you know almost certainly 25 to three
okay
so it's about 36 a year so you're
looking at under 40 years it puts you at
35. yeah and once those mutual funds you
know maybe set a goal and say hey once
the once it hits 75 and it climbs back
up we're cashing out we're gonna
obviously you're gonna have tax
implications and so I would talk to a
tax Pro and look at what that's going to
be and set that money aside in a savings
account so you're ready for tax time
uh but outside of that you know you
might be able to get to the point where
you've got the mortgage down to 75 and
your Investments are at 75 plus and we
can just wipe out the mortgage
instantaneously
okay that's kind of what I was thinking
yeah but you I mean you can hold for now
it's not doing much harm uh if it
emotionally hurts to sell at a loss
right now or sell those shares while
they're low uh we can see what the
market does it may be another year we
just don't know before the market climbs
back up but you'll still have the
mortgage uh hanging around but I mean to
still have your mortgage paid off in
your early 30s is incredible right these
are just very driven people and we love
to see it it's weird and amazing yeah
and I think there's a lot of these
conversations happening right now in a
lot of households with the market being
down and there's a lot of fear and
there's a lot of concern
um and I think yeah this is just one of
those times where you know stay the
course you guys are doing awesome
um and I'm excited to see you guys on
this debt free stage here soon oh yeah
screaming out there you're debt free we
love to see people in their 20s and 30s
getting a hold of this stuff early
because that means the next 30 to 70
years of their life is just going to be
absolutely incredible completely debt
free so exciting well that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books if
you like the show please consider
subscribing leaving a review and sharing
it with a friend big thanks to all the
guys in the booth for running the show
and to my co-host George Campbell and to
you America thanks for listening we'll
be back soon
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]